we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting voicemail I got connecting
abortion and the minimum wage take a
listen to this yeah I want to hear a
Democrat come out and say that an
abortion is oftentimes an economic
necessity and if you think abortion is
murder and you don't want to raise the
minimum wage look at your own hands
you're dripping with blood the bloods on
your hands but of course they're too
mamby-pamby there to fight that card
they will not fight yeah so the point
here that is being made is a good one
whether or not you like the delivery
which is that a lot of abortions are
happening for economic reasons people
are otherwise open to the idea of having
a child but they recognize that their
economic circumstances wouldn't bring
that child into an environment that
would be a positive experience for that
child if you increase the minimum wage
you do enable more people to make the
choice responsibly not to have an
abortion but listen you're thinking like
two or three layers beyond just the the
obvious talking points that we hear from
the right so good luck getting them to
engage with you on that level we've got
a great bonus show coming up for you
today I hope you'll join us you can get
access by becoming a member at WWJ uncom
or by making a $5 a month pledge on
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show I look forward to talking to
you then